hey everybody meet one of my staff
members diana
chang hey Diana hey you're getting your
driver's license I thought because I
like to help my staff members I'd take
you out give you some of my pointers
because I've been driving for a long
time I got my license when I was 16 and
that was well how old do you think I am
like 50 50 something what you are right
that's not the point
you look you look like you're in you're
at most 40s we need to do is look the
camera and say it's plausible plausible
that I'm in my early 30s it's plausible
that Conan is in his early 30s it that's
me
so that's my break right yeah cool huh I
have my own break should use both hands
at all times
yes see I think that's not necessary my
opinion yeah makes it hard to text makes
it hard to make see your hands I'm never
is it tending to they're supposed to be
on actually since airbags came out we
learned that you want to drive with the
lower no one told me that well you might
have learned driving before airbags came
out
[Music]
will you just let that guy pass you and
so now it's like you're a snitch so
you've got to be like no I'm not your
[ __ ] you're my [ __ ] and then you
accelerate and cut him off okay
go faster pass him I'm trying now yo out
the window you're my [ __ ] go yo yeah
you're my [ __ ]
pretty doing the right thing here you're
letting people cross
I think these couple right here is
milking it you know 80 80 is when people
take their time constantly look at your
window so the next time you pass someone
they can hear you when you say you're my
[ __ ] okay go you're my [ __ ] that was
sad
there was an older Asian couple that you
yell did you feel bad doing that okay
and just glared in the window Apple okay
look now they're coming up they just
passed you you just got schooled by a
sienna mini man you're doing great Diana
but we're gonna up the ante now I want
you to learn what it's like to drive
when there are other passengers in the
car and maybe things get a little
distracting so we're gonna swing by over
here and pick up two of my friends you
cool with that okay we might need you to
do a drive-by so you gotta know how to
what thug life no seatbelts not to me
hey man [ __ ] hey hey
Tupac was one of the biggest thugs I
know and he always works yeah
was he cool he was coming at door keys
like Burkle door key
I mean he was just like Kevin Hart I'm
one of the coolest guys I'm Diana am i
cool yeah
you're the fun your friends are gonna
not put me in the friend zone when they
see me first thing that come to mind is
I wanna bump bellies when you scored I
haven't been in zone lots of times and
let me tell you somethin I get in there
I dance we dance you know what I'm
talking about
no I don't you're talking about get the
metaphor you didn't get it yeah Widow
we're talking to a nighttime walker my
nighttime wanted this pudding bout right
here see how much money I'm a prostitute
you're gonna turn me out let it out two
hours you have my trap look I honestly
don't know what you're talking about
I honestly I'm not even doing a bit here
I don't know what your travel money
teaching Diana to drive turn into I'm a
male prostitute you're gonna put me out
and you're gonna come back in an hour
and you want your traffic watching don't
let it get over your lane you know I
still I used to have a tray full of
pennies like in my older what are you
that's ridiculous
here's a penny there you go is this
person cutting you off
[Music]
okay you just really don't know what to
do died in it I got to find somebody to
get mad at right here slow down okay
this penny has your name on it man this
is Diana drivin just driving man power
windows is a big mistake I can't do this
all day if you know spooky business
there you go
doing that good we looking for Mara one
now what do you say Pedro and what 1212
Pedro into what I think he was talking
about San Pedro 12 what is it two
different places you not even drive why
you assuming that Cube knows more about
this neighborhood than I do
why aren't you asking me about this
neighborhood yeah you're absolutely
right about that that's racist a little
racist towards me active it is it Pedro
Pedro I'm not sure I've never been down
here and I'm terrified yeah we're gonna
bite wait have you done crack code
through your butt Kevin how that
conversation go yeah man this is taking
too long
do me a favor blow it in my butt don't
follow rules my thing rules are for
[ __ ] yeah and you know what [ __ ]
get stitches you say this sounds like an
announcement [ __ ] get stitches I
thought I sounded pretty good
bingo Carla that bet you were wild in
your college game oh man I was balls to
the wall I put it up there and I saw it
would stick and I rolled that onion all
the way down I tried everything
everyone dudes okay I did it all
he was a male prostitute paid off my
student loan no no we're gonna get you
guys a pinata
don't settle no ass why you out common
is dress like a male closet
I got you this pinata colder that's okay
oh do you bet the cube I don't look
pinatas around here's Bush what's your
favorite fast food I almost married you
just how much wood could a woodchuck
chuck would you take that into the
studio that goes the number one not bad
it is what the kids are listening to now
Naughty by Nature OPP how can I explain
it
I'll take it frame by frame oh my
goodness that's what's happening now
what we see how oh good what's that a
dispensary
oh are you serious yeah that's great we
got a license she's normally used to
putting drugs in her but it's called the
prison wallet yeah you like sour patch
kids Conan yeah love so yeah there you
go get these I want kilos or sour patch
kids okay could you do me a favor I want
to fill this with we'd just start
stacking them do you have any tape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
same amount of smoke this is like a
Cheech & Chong movie up through your
window we're gonna die we're gonna kill
a good time didn't you get a good career
you're ready to call suddenly all my
anxieties and fears are gone I broke the
law in front of this policeman Goa cops
hello sorry about this sir sir here's a
good thing about me first and foremost
I'm a Christian and what I learned is
that Jesus once walked on water I don't
know what I'm going with this guy thank
you very much officer thank you won't
happen again
here po PO's better get going
[Music]
we got fake this chicken
crack crack cocaine right here I wonder
if you could take this up the but the
but I would do it that's only come on do
it
Diana you are ready for your driver's
test isn't you ready now guys you are
listening the destructor says anything
that you don't like you thought battery
anything
[Applause]
you